we'll take a look at these season
numbers here for mike faltenevich who
will be making his 15th start this
evening for the texas rangers 5.59 here
he does have 51 strikeouts to 19 walks
so far this season
but was in the lead off spot on monday
night had a couple of signals
and he's got another base hit
so tony kemp
into right field and that's how the ball
game gets started
2-2
and he definitely went bad that's strike
three
and there's the first strikeout of the
night for fulton
[Applause]
so their strike three called
olson down looking second strike out of
the inning for fulton heavy
right-hander james caprilian making his
eighth start of the season first start
against the texas rangers first
appearance against the texas rangers
3-2 pitch
driven to center sky bolt is there sky
bolt has it and that's a three-up
three-down inning for james caprilian no
score after one from arlington
pitch on the way there's a swing and a
miss
and a strikeout by brown
time will have to throw him out at first
base to complete it but an 11 pitch
second inning
and another shutout frame
he contacts that one well out into right
field for a base hit
lead man on in the second for the
rangers
a lot of room down the line in right
swing gonna miss up and away
crane gets the strikeout
right through those glass windows and
that's a base hit for sky bolt as he
shoots one the other way
one two to chapman and he swings and
misses
so faulty's struck him out both times
tonight
here's the one-two pitch swinging a miss
he chased a fastball that was up that
pitch was probably ball two
but at one and two uh too close to take
so so lag swings and misses bottom of
the third carpillion off the third base
side of the mountain the big righty
turns and comes to the plate and he gets
him to chase a slider outside not even
close for strike three down he goes a
one two three inning for caprilian
here's the 3-2
swing in a foul tip another change up
and he gets mitch moreland that's the
fifth strikeout now for fulton image
hit hard in the left center field and
that's a base hit
murphy's gonna make a big turn he's
gonna try for two throw to second base
is just a little bit late it was not a
good throw
and murph with a hustle double
[Applause]
was it isaiah was it jonah i can't
remember
this one up and
calhoun sends it into center field for a
base hit
call him out
nope
i heard some boos from the crowd
taking a little while holding the ball
on willy calhoun 3-2 you wonder if chris
woodward they did call him out
he is out
yes he is
so called out and it was the right call
james with the pitch breaking ball swing
and a miss good curveball comes calling
and strikes out low
that is a fourth k on the night for
caprilian
30 runs through the first two games and
maybe those bats a little bit tired here
tonight at globe live field is james
capril to kill the ball very well here
against the texas rangers but mike
foltenevich has also done a very nice
job here for
the home club and he has looked locked
in generating some swings and misses not
just the looking strikes but really good
use of his slider the fastball as well
just had a good one all year long and
there's a change up that he threw to
mitch moreland so papillion four innings
two hits the runs a walk and four
strikeouts mike boltonevich four innings
three hits no runs no walk and five
strikeouts of his own
one-two offering and brown it's a line
drive over the head
of brock holtz in the shift holt was
slightly over to the right side of
second base
and brown with a humpback liner able to
clear the rock star
two
aren't hit on the ground diving stop it
short by andreas his throat off line and
white is on with an infield hit
[Applause]
i can't say i remember that
i think he's gonna ground into a double
play here
yes he is
four six three double play nicely done
by the a's middle infield
and jonah heim will be the batter heim
fly to right his first time up
the o2 and he hits this ball into right
field that's a base hit solace got a
great start he's headed to third
beasley's waiting around third here
comes the throne
not in time
heim
caught up between second and third base
and the rundown will end the ending but
the rangers get that first run of the
game solace scores all the way from
first
on a high double
and it's one to nothing
[Applause]
here's adoles and he's flat out center
and hopped up to second base one to
nothing the rangers lead
that ball hit well deep out to center
field back is blocked and that is gone
garcia leads the yard to straight away
center the rangers lead it two to
nothing
top of the seventh inning the rangers
now lead two to nothing sean murphy
stands in
that one's hit well center field
garcia's gonna turn around and that
baby's goal booming home run by murphy
and it's two to one here's sky bolt
these will just take a flare single
bolt
this could work and it will it drops
fair down the right field line elvis
sanders comes in to score and the a's
have tied it here in the top of the
seventh now the a's are cooking now
chapman in a 2-2 game he swings and he
flies one of left center field it's not
very deep closing on it as garcia can't
get it has to take it on a bounce so
that will score bolt and the a's are in
front three to two
nate lowe low struck out his first time
though
but here's nate lowe driving one deep
out into right center this one's got a
shot it's in the bullpen home run nate
lowe low with the blast into the rangers
bullpen has tied this game at three the
corners are in now with brock holt
and he hits this one over third down the
left field line that one's in
white got a good jump he'll score and
the rangers are back in front
one lined out to right field and a
diving catch by gallow that thing was
never more than six feet off the ground
and joey took the perfect angle to it
and laid out beautifully
and he hits his ball hard out to left
field coming on for white he lays out
and makes a great catch wow
rangers playing a little defense in the
eighth
doley's continues to shine
pitch to garcia that's it high and deep
to right
way back goes loriano at the wall it's
history
an opposite field home run for adoys
it's his second of the night it's his
20th of the year
and the rangers lead it by two it's five
to three
has got his hands full with matt chapman
1-0 and chapman bounces it to third base
high hop throw to second in time and the
ball game is over and a tip of the cap
to joelli rodriguez his first big league
save